[Music]
everyone's how's everyone doing the
spotlight shining in my face I cannot
see any of your faces so I'm just gonna
pretend I'm talking to myself
spoiler alert what you're going to be
getting from me
over the next 30 minutes is exactly as
the title says you'll be hearing about
typography about layout and about design
all in the context of the web so there's
not a lot of JavaScript here I'm afraid
but I do hope you will stick around and
hear me out
given this is Jay s con and all I think
it's safe to assume that everyone in
this room has had some experience with a
web so I'd like everyone to hold this
question in your minds for a little bit
what does the web mean to you for me I
love the web it's the world wide web
right and I was a lucky kid in that even
though our family was far from rich I've
always had a computer in my house
I think my parents need to do it use it
for work or something but I was more
concerned about the games on there and
my first experience with the web if this
works sounds something like this this is
music to my ears
and if you never heard this sound before
well you're obviously not from my
generation and when I think about the
web I think about how amazing it is that
it can connect the world's population in
fact without the web
odds are we would never have crossed
paths and I wouldn't be standing here on
this stage talking to you about the web
so Star Trek discovery anybody okay one
oh come on man so this beautiful woman
is Michelle Yeoh one of the greatest
female action stars of all time and
pride of Malaysians
everywhere now when she when she first
got to Hollywood people were amazed that
she could speak English so well and she
in turn was equally amazed that people
in Hollywood had such a terrible grasp
of world geography seeing as they did
not know where Malaysia was I'm sure
many people from America and Europe know
exactly where Southeast Asia is I mean
look around you look at all the experts
no offense if you are one but I have
also met people whose idea of Asia was
limited to China India or Japan so this
is a very helpful map that I've created
to show people where exactly we are so
Southeast Asia is made up of 11
countries and every single one of them
has their own distinct culture English
is taught in schools across the region
but we have so many other languages as
well and of the world's seven point six
billion people only four point nine
percent are native English speakers but
fifty one point two percent of websites
are in English so something isn't quite
right about this ratio the world is
beautiful because of its cultural
diversity language is a part of a
society's cultural heritage and is
especially important for the maintenance
of it now the web is an informational
medium in that people go online to find
out about things even if you're going
online to purchase something don't you
need in from
about the product you're going to buy so
the priority is always content the web
is only useful to the people who can
understand the content on it which is
why I'm slightly comforted to know that
internationalization is a priority at
the w3c it is crucial that a technology
meant to be ubiquitous supports the
creation of local content across the
world that every writing system in the
world can be correctly rendered on the
web just to prove a point these are the
various scripts in use in Southeast Asia
and they can all be displayed and laid
out correctly on the web today with
better Unicode support and phone
technologies for the individual
characters as well as various CSS
properties for overall layout we now
have a means to carve out a space on the
web that truly belongs to each of us
that truly feels like home before I go
any further I really should introduce
myself my name is quitting and I'm from
sorry I'm from Malaysia I used to play
basketball full time and it was what
kick-started my web career I also has
asked the harm they've introduced I have
an inordinate love of CSS to the point
where I'm compelled to write and speak
about it including hijacking a J's
concession to sneak in some CSS talk now
somebody once asked me this question do
developers even care about typography
and I think they do but maybe I'm wrong
I usually am how many of you think
typography is important thank you now
typography has always been an integral
part of human-computer interaction and
software design there's a very good
reason why Apple has an entire section
dedicated to typography in the Apple
developers human interface guidelines
and you may disagree with me but I feel
that as a front-end developer the
copyright impacts how our sites or
applications look so we too have a share
of the responsibility in the design of
our products
Oliver brightenstein said this in his
article back in 2006 and he reiterated
that the web as a medium is all about
information textual content is the most
straightforward
of delivering information on the web and
whether we like it or not
topography is increasingly becoming what
differentiates a good website from that
let's be honest people are superficial
and they're really short attention spans
these days the typography layout and
design of your site or application are
like the clothes you wear and people
make judgments of their first
impressions of you or your product based
on what they see there are many
definitions of typography out there and
I personally like this one by Garrett no
J letters are the building blocks of a
writing system regardless of language
now I believe there's a pretty diverse
mix of languages spoken by the audience
here today and while a large number of
these languages are alphabetic Chinese
is not one of them Chinese is a
logographic writing system where each
character is composed with in a uniform
Square this allows Chinese to be very
efficiently regardless of whether it is
set horizontally or vertically and until
proven otherwise it seems that the
Chinese script developed separately from
the proto-sinaitic script which were the
origins of alphabetic languages this is
why the Western languages in Europe are
inherently different from the Eastern
languages in Asia alphabetic languages
which originated from the Phoenician
alphabet combine a small set of letters
to form all the words the language needs
for the purpose of communication Chinese
characters on the other hand number in
the tens of thousands each a unique
glyph that can express meaning on their
own or be used in combination with other
glyphs for example hippopotamus this is
an English word that takes 12 letters to
spell in Chinese we only need two
characters per ma lubinski filter this
is a German word that takes 14 letters
to spell in Chinese we can say bunny
green - oi director this is an Irish
word of 21 letters and again in Chinese
show you what can I say Chinese is a
concise language
the appearance of the earliest letter
forms was directly influenced by the
tools that were used to create them and
they continually involved in tandem with
the limitations of the technologies of
their time so take the Latin alphabet
for example which is derived from Greek
the earliest letters were San serif when
writing was done with a heartbeat pen
service may have came about due to a
transition to a square cut writing
implement like a flat stiff brush later
scribes and copyists used quill pens and
as demand for written matter grew they
developed more efficient styles of
writing evolving the letter forms yet
again when it comes to classifying
script styles Latin based scripts can
broadly be placed into two big
categories of serifs and sans serifs a
Chinese characters also changed a lot
since their origins it's just that
Chinese writing went through the entire
process of development and evolution way
earlier than Europe the key implement of
Chinese writing is the brush calligraphy
was and still is one of the most highly
regarded Chinese arts the works of
famous calligraphers were used as the
basis for carving wood blocks for
printing these days typefaces used for
printing Chinese publications can
broadly be classified into the following
families we have some tea also known as
Ming tea kaity funk song tea and Haiti
now the last two are 20th century
creations so it's really recent Chinese
typefaces are extremely challenging to
create simply due to the volume of
glyphs required the average number of
glyphs for a Chinese system font clocks
in and around 35,000 glyphs give or take
a few thousand and typefaces that have
enough lift coverage to be used in body
copy are usually made by foundries as
very few independent type designers have
the bandwidth for them now language and
writing have a lot human beings to
communicate ideas and record history for
thousands of years and we've written on
almost anything we could get our hands
on but right now the medium of our time
is the screen and the browser our types
are our font files and we've replaced
typesetting with composing sticks with
yes but remember this an electronic
display is a proxy medium whatever we
see displayed on a screen comes from
data encoded as electronic signals and
the heart of electronic displays is
light it is transient we cannot reach
out and touch light now the web isn't
even 38 and this young medium is nothing
like we've seen before
it is dynamic and interactive now some
designers especially those who aren't
used to especially those who are used to
having absolute control over their final
presentations tend to find this
disturbing right and although it may be
tempting to view the web as simply print
expressed on an electronic screen it is
not it is a unique medium of its own
when we talk about typography on the web
one of the first things that comes to
mind is web fonts so let's start off
with some basics what is a font now in
the world of metal typesetting this is a
font which refers to a complete set of
metal types that were used to type two
entire pages of text and if you can see
the tiny text label this set being shown
is four Caslon 12-point but in the
digital world these are funds
specifically font files for both analog
and digital fonts you can think of them
as collections of glyphs which begs the
next question what are glyphs now a
glyph is the specific shape of a letter
or character in a particular font so
this is a glyph this is a blue that's
also a glyph in the digital world
everything is later so glyphs can be
described as with an array of pixels or
collections of vector images or parts of
Bezier curves in straight lines
different font formats store information
about the font like the glyphs they're
encodings metadata about the font etc
differently based on how their
specifications were written because you
know data formats right and if you've
ever used web fonts before you'd have
seen at least some of these formats
and if you've ever wondered why there
was so many well this little bit of
history involved here so the earlier
spawns were pixel based bitmaps which
didn't work out so well when it came to
high-resolution printing so a lot of
smart people work to solve this problem
and one of the solutions came from Adobe
founder John Warnock he created
PostScript in 1985 which was the very
first vector font and it really took off
so TrueType was Apple and Microsoft's
answer to Adobe's phone monopoly and
eventually Microsoft turned to Adobe and
together they came up with
OpenType now Microsoft also came up with
e o T which is embedded open type a
proprietary format for use on webpages
and although they tried to submit this
to the w3c as a recommendation it was
rejected in favor of more web open font
format
now what too is simply an improvement of
a wolf with significantly better
compression rates on the practical side
of things we use the font phase rule to
declare a list of different font formats
in the hopes that our fonts will show up
correctly in as many browsers as
possible the number of web formats that
we need to declare has decreased over
the years and right now you can pretty
much get away with declaring just woof
and woof to the font face rule has more
descriptors but only these two the font
family and source are mandatory so if
either either one of them are absent the
entire font face rule is ignored now the
font family descriptor is simply a label
that we reference in other CSS
declarations so even if you're using a
font like Helvetica you can actually
call it dumplings and it would still
work then the source descriptor is a
comma separated list of external
references or locally installed form
phase names it is made up of a
declaration of the font files location
and an optional font hint so if the
browser doesn't support a particular
font format stated in the hint it won't
even bother loading the font at all so
the next three descriptors for style
weight and stretch are used to match
styles to a particular typeface in later
declarations so technically
you could assign a black typeface to a
font weight of 100 and proceed to
confuse your entire team who cannot
figure out why setting a weight of 100
gives them this massively black typeface
perhaps an idea for April Fool's Day
hashtag don't get fired then we have the
Unicode range descriptor which allows us
to create composite fonts that mix
glyphs from different fronts for
different scripts so sometimes the Latin
characters for Chinese ones don't look
particularly nice this is more apparent
on the older Windows systems to be
honest so the unicorn range descriptor
allows us to specify a specific font
file to be loaded for individual code
points or a range of code points so in
this example I've created a font family
called Haiti Plus because you know
naming things is hard but Haiti plus
we'll use the Haiti SC font for
everything but the second rule will tell
the browser to use the mechanical font
for all Latin characters instead the
Firefox dev tools has a font panel which
shows which fonts are loaded on your
page and although it's really small you
can try to squint and see that both hate
ESC and Mechanica are loaded for my
custom font family hating plus now the
per page does not contain any Latin
characters meccanica will not be loaded
at all because it's not needed now fond
descriptors and CSS properties look very
similar but are two completely different
things Chris Lilley who chaired the
group that developed font face explained
it very well in his CSS talk that
properties are requests for styling and
descriptors and descriptions of
capabilities so a font-weight:bold
within a font face rule means that this
font can do both while a
font-weight:bold applied as a applied as
a property means pls style this element
with a font that can do both it's kind
of a subtle difference so these here are
CSS font properties so from what I've
seen properties like font size font
weight and font style are pretty
commonly used font stretch maybe a
little bit less and the last two which
are font size adjust and font synthesis
almost never seen used in the wild
before so let's talk a bit about those
two which were newly added to the font
level 3 specification font size adjust
was put in to address legibility issues
because faced us with low X Heights may
sometimes be less legible especially
when they're triggered as a fallback
font we can set the value of this
property to an aspect ratio of the
first-choice font so any fallback fonts
trigger will have the font size adjusted
to match this ratio font synthesis was
put in to address the issue of four
bolts and four italics because sometimes
the true italic or heavier version of a
font doesn't exist or the browser can't
find it and so the browser will try to
compensate unfortunately the end result
often isn't pretty
so with this property you can set it to
a value of none to tell the browser you
know it's fine appreciate the effort but
no thank you now for the fun stuff font
feature properties which were introduced
in fonts level 3 more than font
technologies allow fonts to contain a
lot more glyphs than before so we can
utilize a variety of typographic
features like sorceress ligatures or
start numerals and so on and perhaps
some of you might be wondering what's
the point why why do we want to have all
these typographic features as a waste of
time but no they are part and parcel of
good typography which is necessary to
hold your readers attention now the
written word is a transference of speech
which is hurt into something visual
which is seen good speakers will vary
their cadence they will use gestures
they'll emphasize certain words
typographic features like small caps and
correct use of italics and punctuation
they do the same for text now other
features like old-style numerals and
ligatures they help maintain typographic
color to make reading more comfortable
so these are the features you can turn
on via CSS but note that the font you're
using must have these features to begin
with so this lot up here are the
features most often mentioned at web
typography talks but almost nobody talks
about font variant east-asian what this
property does is allow for glyph
substitution and positioning in East
Asian text if you're unfamiliar with
harm characters it may seem like East
Asian
just share the same glyphs but it
actually depends Han unification
involves assigning the same code point
to different glyphs and has been quite a
controversial issue which we will not
get into but the point is that the same
code point can have variant lifts
depending on the language being used
like simplified Chinese Gliss versus
traditional Chinese glyphs Japanese
glyphs have their own specification
known as JIS or Japanese industrial
standard and they too have alternate
glyphs for the same character so this
property allows us to toggle these
variant glyphs and when I mentioned
OpenType earlier I also want to point
out that in September of 2016 version
1.8 of the specification introduced
OpenType font variations it was in joint
development by Microsoft Google Apple
and Adobe an open type variable font is
one in which the equivalent of multiple
individual fonts can be compactly
packaged within a single font file and
this is potentially a big plus when it
comes to performance especially
significant for funds with large glyph
sets like all the CJK fonts in addition
to that the dynamism of variable fonts
is perfect for the web medium and opens
up the possibility of new kinds of
responsive typography if you're
interested in seeing how variable fonts
behave you'll have to check out access
praxis by Lauren's penny which is
essentially a playground for the
available very favorable fonts on the
web so Taipei based type foundry avec
technology aka wending cards II created
the first Chinese variable font called
one things in C hey and you can play
with it on access praxis so vertical
writing is traditionally East Asian for
Han characters which are used in Chinese
Japanese and Korean but when it comes to
design we can lay up text in all
directions if we so choose so I want to
introduce the writing mode property
which deals specifically with vertical
text you literally turn the browser on
its side now some people might be saying
that's no big deal we can already do
this with CSS transforms but it's kind
of different
this is what happens to your text when
the different values of writing mode are
applied the default is horizontal top to
bottom to change the direction to
vertical we use vertical RL or vertical
LR now when we rotate text it's not only
the lines that change direction because
each line contains individual letters or
characters and they have an orientation
as well so for text orientation the
initial value is mixed browsers are
smart enough to tell which languages can
can be typeset both vertically and
horizontally or in one direction only so
Chinese characters for example will
always be displayed upright while
horizontal only languages will have
their characters rotated when vertical
the text orientation property lets you
control this and you can always make all
the characters up right or sideways if
you want to one more relevant property
is text combined up right this addresses
the issue of numerals or abbreviations
in vertical text so a very common use
case is dates especially for Taiwan
where they use the minke or calendar
this property that says fit all the
digits into the width of one character
and display them upright no browser
supports in the digits value yet which
allows us to dictate how many digits are
acceptable to be squeezed into this
space the range allowed is supposed to
be between two and four characters but
for now with the old value there is no
limit so you could sort of put a word
like hippopotamus in there it will work
but horribly squished now laying out
content in a different direction does
require a change in perspective and I
gleaned quite a few insights from
working with vertical layout for example
the techniques I was so used to for
centering items worked a bit differently
when it came to vertical layout to
vertically send her a block setting the
top and bottom margins to auto actually
does work unlike in horizontal writing
which is great but trying to Center
something horizontally is an exercise in
pain the directions of top right bottom
left to start getting a bit confusing
when you have rotated Latin text so you
have this header and you want some extra
spacing
between the header and the paragraph you
set the margin on the bottom of the
header or to the left it's actually the
left so it's kind of weird which is why
we have a CSS logical property
specification which introduces the new
CSS properties that are flow relative
equivalents of physical box model
properties so these properties use
things like block start and block end or
inline start and inline end instead of
left and right the specification is in
the thick of working draft status but
I'm really eager to see developed and
implement it but now support is kind of
spotty now before I discovered the
writing mode property I did wonder to
myself if it was possible to do vertical
typesetting on the web and the answer is
a resounding yes all three properties I
covered earlier were used for this
particular demo and this is a layout I
built for displaying Chinese text with a
toggle that allowed readers to switch
between vertical and horizontal layouts
it wasn't as straightforward as I
thought it would be because a tricky
thing was getting the images to
orientate correctly now it would have
been nice to have a media query for
writing mode so I could lay out my
images accordingly with the picture
element but that doesn't exist yet so I
ended up working around the image issue
with you know CSS transforms instead so
yes there is still work to be done to
further develop Chinese typesetting on
the web and for all non latin-based
languages actually so the Chinese layout
taskforce which I am a part of aims to
document requirements for the layout and
presentation of text for the major
languages of China when those languages
are used by web standards the document
will provide requirements for the
development of w3c standards affected by
languages in used in China including
Hansel Mongolian Tibetan and Weger
scripts now implementing vertical
layouts has become much easier as
browser vendors continue to improve the
functionality of their products and this
opens up an aspect of graphic design
that isn't often seen on the web at the
moment for example you can make a
bookshelf style list of Post
just CSS something like this can be done
by applying vertical RL to each list
item plus some padding and insert box
shadows for the visual effect and
another idea can be for headers because
for horizontal languages you wouldn't
lay out long chunks of text vertically
because that just makes things hard to
read but using vertical text for short
titles or headers can really break up
the monotony of a long page other subtle
users of vertical text could be for tags
on blog posts where the information is
not critical to the main content so
laying it out vertically doesn't
adversely affect the reading experience
for language is meant to be read
horizontally from top to bottom vertical
textured largely be decorative we don't
want to compromise the reading
experience for long-form passages so and
smaller screens we can make use of media
queries to revert to a horizontal layout
that makes better use of limited space
now conversely there are instances where
text rotate it vertically can work on
narrow screen sizes as well perhaps you
realize that the hamburger menu is not
the best mobile UI pattern that we came
up with so depending on the number of
links that you have in your navigation
perhaps laying them out vertically on
the side edge could be a design worth
considering and I'm sure many of you can
come up with even more interesting
design that utilize vertical layouts
statistically there aren't that many
sites that use the writing mode property
and when I started building vertical
layouts grit hadn't landed yet so I used
Flex box for a lot of my layouts flex
box support is great I mean it has wider
coverage than border-radius right but
flex box with writing mode doesn't play
too well together I'll be honest there
are quite a large number of cross
browser issues like in Firefox if you
don't specify a width on the element
with a vertical writing mode it just
gets kicked off the page there working
on it by the way but that doesn't mean
we should shy away from using vertical
text altogether in fact there's never
been a better time than now to live on
the cutting edge because evergreen
browsers are a thing now with bug fixes
and new features being shipped faster
than ever
CSS bit I feel
the best rollouts of a new major CSS
feature ever with almost all the major
browsers shipping it in March last year
by now more than 70 percent of the
market is using a browser that supports
grip and here's a little secret I
discovered by raising bucks we find when
trying out new features we're actually
showing browser vendors that these
features are in demand and this works
both ways if we don't use features
simply because they are buggy browser
vendors will think that nobody really
cares about that feature and choose to
fix more pressing bugs instead now if
more of us use those features and raise
the bucks we discover it sends a signal
to browser vendors that people are using
these features and encourage them to
address related bucks sooner rather than
later
like what Yuna said this morning so
here's a long list of resources I
referred to when preparing this talk and
I'll share these slides for anybody
who's interested and if you need
inspiration for vertical layouts the
today yokel Weber wat site has a really
nice showcase John Simmons also has an
experimental layout lab where she
showcases all the different things that
are now possible with modern CSS and
even if you don't end up using any of
what I've covered today immediately in
your next project I mean your jeaious
guys aren't you I hope that you keep
these techniques and properties in the
back of your mind and maybe one day when
you're tired of building the same old
layouts again and again you'll reach for
them and create something amazing thank
you
[Applause]